[Music]
we can up every these this thing you
think I will suggest to my coach on me
is right hidden at the view the
tradition of moko Jumbies is a special
form of stilt-walking named after a West
African spirit who watches over villages
thanks to his towering height in times
of celebration groups of Trinidadian
dancers pay tribute to the spirit but
for Adrian loco Jumby is part of his
everyday life
my name is John Young and I've been
walking stilts for 21 years the highest
I walked with my dance group is called
future Jumbies and it's a school for
anyone to learn to walk sticks the a
previous with dear Petronius ters we got
our shoes attached and then we have a
nice tie up and then we can have someone
raises up between starting on one foot
steps and then they gradually go up you
have overcome the fear for
for Paulina sake the people in lunatic
no risk no reward
these are the dance move on stilts
we got limbo stoop
Lara butterfly and the MOCA tree in the
hardest movers the a split that's where
you take a Pathan my favorite part of
moko Jumbies dancing is when my whole
team that I trained just killing it I
feel a joy but then doing nothing when I
see my team give in a day all and doing
their routines I feel a sense of pride
and some time feel like sharing at it
now by sense of bringing everyone
together
Oh hula is the language of the heart and
therefore the heartbeat of the Hawaiian
people and we tell our dancers
everything needs steps your hair your
toenail your eyelashes it needs to dance
now you only go if I eat pain you know
[Music]
[Applause]
within three days the competition
tickets are sold out those tickets are
like gold they only bring the best of
the best and so we're very honored to be
able to participate the most prestigious
part of Merrie Monarch is the miserable
hula competition which is the women's
solo competition 12 hollows are allowed
to choose their very best answer our
contestant this year is chemical any car
can you Lenny is a professional hula
dancer and we chose her for many
different reasons we wanted to pretty
cool not just the dancer but as a person
you had no cold yeah one of my favorite
parts about Merrie Monarch week is that
we go to Kilauea to be respects to Pele
with the fire goddess the goddess of
creation and it really puts into
perspective where you are in this world
and in this pool of journey
[Music]
I've wanted to be in Merrie Monarch
since I was a little kid there was a lot
of times where I thought I would never
it would never happen for me but pretty
much most of my hula journey has been
working towards this moment which is
tomorrow professionally I've been doing
it since 2009 there's a difference
between dancing hula and hollow and
dancing hula professionally the antique
furniture is is like American Chinese
and not the authentic Chinese food and
hotels here's what you see beautiful men
and women brightly colored hair pieces
and leis which are all plastic but you
won't see the skill you won't see the
love that you would at the Merrie
Monarch festival for Merrie Monarch we
practice every day for I would say 3 to
4 months they're intense can we try to
and one more time what do you think
waiting invitation you need one
invitation come on you guys get your
head game on the biggest misconception
about hula is that it's easy all the
dancers and you quote me on this have
bad knees all of them so when you see a
beautiful hula dancer its gliding across
the stage she's hurting she's hurting
really bad because nobody walks around
with bent knees you know 6 inches off
the ground blisters you get blisters on
your feet every single part of your body
needs to work you should be gasping for
air but you can you need to look exactly
the same as when you first started
you can bend your knees and swing your
hips and have this upper body carriage
that's really upgrade I'm making look
effortless that's what you wanna mention
ladies and gentlemen welcome to this
Aloha Hula competition if I gave the
performance of a lifetime if I gave
everything I had to that one performance
those 14 minutes up there just me
you're just the vessel for all of these
people that came before you for all of
the knowledge that you have and it's
your responsibility to share that it's
your responsibility to perpetuate but it
would be so nice to hear my name being
called
I know ladies are doing this for 2016
Kaylee
[Applause]
you know I don't dance hula just to be a
missile Ola I do it because I just
because I love it and III can't explain
to you why I do I think I think it's
something you're just burning ladies and
gentlemen this is the thousand hand bot
hits on the dance
pretty cool huh one would think that a
performance this difficult and precise
would require all five senses well think
again because all these dancers can't
hear the music making this performance
even cooler
[Music]
founded in 1987 the China disabled
people's performing art troupe performs
eloquent dances plays and operas the
music is performed by the visually
impaired and the dance numbers are
performed by those hard of hearing the
thousand hanboks sapa dance is the
troops most popular performance it was
also one of the most difficult dances
for them to learn and that's where Xiang
Tian comes in she and other instructors
use sign language to help conduct the
dancers white campus all parties him
with all watched another circle whoa
Chavo national under-20 value back now
Santa Monica what you find for Jindal
yeah aren't you get me didn't you don't
have my Susanna sort with you go take a
pin Boucher Utne on him someone come
down
you may come high sugar sure hold on
another full total funds on three each
of the Kanawha I'm sure you may see our
feelings I mean without show for say one
more sound down hammering down again to
young people wonderful general more
detail they also realized that spending
time together off stage would not only
enhance their friendship but their
performance on stage as well
[Music]
in bings case he and other musicians
developed their own technique for
playing without being able to see on TV
a co2 la femme fatale Rio de Janiero hey
ese Chico oh no you see
sang-ho de pusi time before time average
is pretty warm okay Ron Tatia young
children
Cointreau booty booty - AHA no Mogambo -
yo - ha hey ese orientation for don't
perform any end of a civil war
hi autographic we are 1300 many years
one Chilean Congo fungal no shita de
Paco gotcha modular Joshua Salomon
Sangha young food important raw mango to
Overland on Seymour Tom Gorman the yeah
monkey
ta-da sanjayan Pahoa yo pay the tuition
for Bahamas in Salerno work at Hammond
that reaches in four different areas
here call me that she says you are
[Music]
[Music]
practicing everybody pick another woman
de la masturba divisional number of - Oh
moody chamber on they come in
da-da-da-da-da approach a legitimate
right he stopped a vehicle a telenovela
star visit him but the universe pipe and
if I recall a model employer whom are in
an overly worship in Havana consider
Leah new this year the purana delay
protego I mean it didn't really prepare
that it's a true with a Fenian gondola
gondola on giv named Walker Alejandro
Livadia medium height in relation to
hurry opinion have a president and SRT
Avenue karna linear at two Muslim
carnelian Alberta a little Cardinal
brother hello Hannah
I do wonder nearly company practices
number I Eastern insanity television
like this ordinary returning even a
petition we're in a copy of the
universal area where under pamda
endorsed at all what about under Lucas a
legal Aaron starting model a and the
g-wiz I was on a very important thing
here
[Music]
nomicon sankalpa gang patata versa yg3
had originated on a basilica de otra
amorini where nominal manicure angle
it's a miracle you through there near
another
about 30 item e38 regalia the molecular
is some Skyrim or are there is another
honor Jared if I remember yeah I don't
like a level editor but in the numerator
and blood on the wrecked our like up
here you know me and the manager said
ìdo cuz I really curate our particular
develop a poor in an energy wisdom comes
early give order to Ibaka early in the
world and the you than Hank Azaria
you
[Music]